FEMALE SPEAKER: Thanks for
coming out and joining us today
to hear Josey talk
about his new book,
and his voyage to make bread.
JOSEY BAKER: [LAUGHS]
So I've known Josey
for about three years.
He started his bread journey
right around the time
that I guess I met him, right?
So he'll give you a
bit more of the story.
But I think in good
Google fashion,
we have an awesome video
to really highlight
the history of how Josey started
to start this bread journey,
so I'm just going
to play that video
and then afterwards, Josey will
give us a bit of a talk, so.
JOSEY BAKER (VOICEOVER):
I've wrestled
a lot with the
question now than I'm
so invested in this project.
Do I want to be doing this?
How long will I want
to be doing this?
Because I haven't been
doing it for that long,
and I've been doing it in a
really different way than I'm
about to be doing it.
JOSEY BAKER: It's
like in college.
You meet someone new.
You're just like, can't stop
thinking about them, you know?
And you're staying up late.
And like, you don't care.
You're going to be late
for class tomorrow.
You don't give a
shit, because you're
going to go hang
out with them later.
It's going to be good.
That's the way I feel about my
girlfriend-- and about bread.
My name is Josey Baker.
I'm a bread baker.
The first time that I
baked a loaf of bread
was not that long ago, it
was 2 and 1/2 years ago.
JOSEY BAKER
(VOICEOVER): It was so
exciting to take the
finished loaf of bread
and bring it, and
give it to somebody.
When I approached the owners
of Mission Pie I said,
maybe I could rent
space from you
when you're not using your oven.
It was written into
the contract that we
had that I need to have to
at least 10 loves of bread
available for walk-in customers.
Some days, it felt
like 80 loves,
you know, in just
like a few hours.
For most people, the best
loaf of bread that they've had
is either a loaf that
they made themselves,
or a loaf that they
got from a neighbor.
Somebody that made it
like a matter of hours
before, and really like, put
part of themself into it,
you know?
CHARLIE HALLOWELL: Josey has the
few of these simple things that
just help, like
his heart is open.
You can just tell he has
a commitment to serving
the people around
him, and his friends,
and the people he loves.
He has an advantage in that
way where he can be a novice,
and still have this
remarkable product.
JOSEY BAKER
(VOICEOVER): Most people
have what it takes to
make something yummy.
It's all the other
stuff that separates out
the people who make
a few jars of jam,
sell it to their neighbors-- to
the people who end up actually
making a successful
business out of it.
Because it's a lot
more than that.
Jesus, I had no idea.
JEREMY TOOKER:
One of the reasons
that Josey's bread is so
good is because he will never
say how good it is.
Because that's the way he sees
it-- I could always be better.
JODI GEREN: We
always knew that we
wanted to open another location.
I think that you
probably had your hands
in like, five different
potential leases--
JEREMY TOOKER: Yes.
JODI GEREN: --around the city.
JEREMY TOOKER: And I
basically lied to everyone
to get them to jump
on board the project.
JODI GEREN: Yeah, so--
JEREMY TOOKER: I can
do it for 150, 50,000.
No problem.
When we found the space,
it was a bit bigger
than we were looking
for for a second cafe.
And then, we started to
think about what else
we could do in the space.
I think it was falling asleep
one night, I was like--ah!
Baker.
Just put Josey Baker in there.
JOSEY BAKER: That wasn't on my
radar, getting my own space.
But as soon as he asked me I was
like oh, if I'm going to do it,
like this is a
golden opportunity.
So let's go for it.
I think right here
actually, about right
here is going to
be our toast bar.
We're installing this oven,
this huge oven from Italy,
it's crazy.
This will be the
mill room right here.
This is the mill.
I can't even believe it,
you want to look inside?
This little string
and rod controls
how quickly the grains fall in.
JODI GEREN: He's one
of those people that
could learned how
to do anything.
So for us, we're just really
lucky that it's bread,
and we're really lucky that he
was naive enough at one point
to take us up on
this crazy offer.
JOSEY BAKER: I hadn't
gotten very far
in my conceiving of
this whole thing.
I didn't know where I was
going to get the money.
I was like, OK.
I need like, $30,000 dollars,
$35,000 dollars or something.
I'll like, I'll ask
around, and I'll find that.
And I did ask around,
and I found it.
It very quickly, I realized that
that was nowhere near enough.
Oh geez, I need like,
I need that much again.
I need that much again six
to eight months after that.
And that number is
you know, times 5.
CHARLIE HALLOWELL: I like,
invested in his business a lot,
like every dime of my
savings, basically.
And I love Josey, but it was
definitely like blind faith.
JOSEY BAKER (VOICEOVER):
This is a big commitment.
JOSEY BAKER: No problem.
MALE SPEAKER: Was
this back there?
JOSEY BAKER: It was hiding
back there, hiding on you.
JOSEY BAKER (VOICEOVER):
Someone's got to make all of it
happen.
And if it's your
project, you're going
to be the one to
make it all happen.
None of those
people you hire are
going to care about
it as much as you do.
JOSEY BAKER: It's
hardest to find things
when they're right
in front of you.
This is our kiosk,
this is our area
for people to come in
and sample the wares.
And this is copyrighted, so
you know, don't try to copy
this, anybody.
We're making toast,
you how to make toast.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Mmm.
Now we know what
treats to buy for you.
JOSEY BAKER: Mmm.
We're going to be doing this
until the place is built out,
which will be, you know,
couple months from now.
MALE SPEAKER: You're
building now, yeah?
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
Yeah, a couple months.
MALE SPEAKER: Really?
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Really nice spot.
JOSEY BAKER: Open it up.
JOSEY BAKER (VOICEOVER):
It's taking a long time.
It's taking a lot longer
than I think any of us
thought it was going to take.
Planning on opening in
June of 2012, and then that
doesn't happen.
OK we're going to plan
on opening in August.
That doesn't-- OK, we're going
to plan on opening in November.
JOSEY BAKER: I was in
here the other night,
and it was pouring rain.
Water started just
pouring out of this.
It started just
pouring out of that.
This hole in the ceiling,
this hole on the ceiling.
I go into my
walk-in, and there's
like an inch of
water on the ground.
JOSEY BAKER (VOICEOVER): It's
always just been me, you know?
How can I figure
out how to just make
this work by delivering
the bread on my bike?
By walking around and
asking people if I could
you know, rent space from them?
Now, I have a bakery.
I've got a lot of
loans to pay off.
I'm invested in this project
with these people you know,
and that we're now really
relying on each other.
That's scary,
because I've wondered
how long am I going
to want to do this?
Because I haven't been
doing it for that long,
and I've been doing it in a
really different way than I'm
about to be doing it.
JOSEY BAKER: We're out in
Chico at Dave Miller's house
at his bakery for
one last trip out
before I open up the bakery.
Bread is what brought us
together, and a lot of what
we talk about.
He's been doing this
for a really long time,
and I'm only like now
engaging in certain questions
that he engaged in
a long time ago.
You know, and so
that's why I mean,
he's the closest thing
I have to a mentor.
He has answers to a lot
of the questions I have,
and he's really
happy to share them.
DAVE MILLER: That
is the one problem
with doing everything yourself.
You don't have anyone to
blame when it doesn't out.
JOSEY BAKER: Totally.
Now I have the opposite issue
with having Wendy's help.
It's like we look at two loves
of bread and like, one of them
is perfect, and one of them
is like a little lopsided,
I'm like, fuck.
Wendy-- Wendy made the
one that looks perfect.
In San Fransisco I don't
feel like there's really
any room for me to slow down.
And I get out
here, and it's just
like, everything's
going to be fine.
It's going to be shot in
the dark for everybody, man.
It's, it's fine.
I'd rather--
WENDY: It's better to have not--
JOSEY BAKER: I'd rather
for the first few days
not have enough than
have like-- that's
just, like psychologically,
that's damaging, you know?
We're trying to guesstimate
daily numbers right now.
We're going to do it the first
day, we're going to be wrong.
WENDY: Yeah.
JOSEY BAKER: We're going
to adjust the second day,
we're going to be wrong.
WENDY: I mean if we
sell out, sell out.
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah, we
not superheroes, right?
We're bakers.
I think that most
people probably,
regardless of what they do, if
you're committed to anything,
you're going to wonder
whether or not you want to be.
Awesome.
JOSEY BAKER
(VOICEOVER): Seems kind
of boring to not be
committed to something.
Really good things take time.
JOSEY BAKER: Oh,
fucking shit man.
This good?
OK.
Yeah, yeah. [LAUGHING] I
can see that, feel that.
JOSEY BAKER
(VOICEOVER): We're not
trying to like to become
a croissant master,
or a cookie master,
or whatever, you know?
I just want to make bread.
I wish that I could give other
people the love and the focus
that I've found through it.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSEY BAKER:
[CLEARS THROAT] Thank you.
Thanks for coming very much.
It's really exciting
to do events like this,
and it is always
amazing to me when
people that I don't
already know come.
So thanks for coming.
Yeah, and like I said at
the end, wow, there I am.
Like I said at the
end of that movie
there, that was quite a trip
down memory lane for me.
I hadn't watched that
in a little while.
And we opened The Mill
in February of last year,
so it's been almost
a year and a half.
And that feels
like very long ago.
But I said at the
end of the movie
there that I wish that
I could give people
the love and the focus that
I've found through bread.
And you know, little
did I know that that's
what this book is really
allowing me to do.
And it's been really amazing
to be hearing from people
who have the book, and
are baking from it,
and are having a lot
of success at home.
And I get lots of emails that
are filled with exclamation
points because people are
so pumped up because they--
you know a common
thing I hear is
that folks have tried to bake
a few loaves of bread at home.
Or they just thought that
they weren't a baker,
they didn't have what it took.
And for whatever reason,
they decided to get the book
and give it a shot.
And lone behold,
they are a baker,
just like you all are bakers.
Because I mean four years
ago, literally four years ago,
I hadn't baked bread at all.
And my friend
George was traveling
through San Fransisco, and
he had a little container
with a little brown lump in it.
And I said George, what is
that gross looking stuff?
And he said, it's a
sourdough starter.
I was like well, why do you
have a sourdough starter?
You can't bake good
bread at home, right?
Kind of laughed, he
said no, you can man.
Just try it.
So he wrote down
some instructions,
left some sourdough with me.
And a week later I tried it,
and just was totally in love,
and haven't been able
to stop ever since.
And I'll go through, what
I'll do is I'll maybe,
I'll go through my slide show.
And I'll probably jump around
and jump through, speed it
up a little bit
quicker than usual.
I'm not used to doing the
slide show after we've all
seen the movie, so I'll try
to keep from boring you.
This is my first blog
entry in August of 2010.
Holy moly, it's happening.
Hi friends.
I'm selling bread,
and people like it.
This is so totally
rad, it's making
my eyes pop out of my face.
Not really, but I'm pumped up.
And so it really was-- and
this is just a few months ago.
Went from that first blog
entry of baking at home
to being on billboards and bus
stops around San Fransisco.
This is unreal.
This is for this
great company here
in San Fransisco
called Good Eggs.
They're like an online
farmer's market,
and I sell a lot of
my bread through them.
And they were really
influential and helpful to me
early on in my business,
because-- actually,
and some of you may--
I feel like you,
and maybe some others of
you, I actually-- Google
was super helpful.
Yeah, super helpful
to my business
early on, because I
was doing, I started
selling my bread through
a bread subscription.
So I'd say hey, give me $20, and
I'll bake you a loaf per week
for four weeks.
So I started doing that
just word of mouth,
and then I had an
article written about it.
And so Stranger
started doing it,
and then I started doing
it at some businesses
around the city.
And I had a really good
experience doing that here
at Google where some days
I would drop off like,
50 loaves of bread.
And that was one of
a handful of things
that made me feel
like, holy shit.
This might be for real.
And so this was in, this
is Thanksgiving of 2010.
I had that article
written about me,
and I was just baking at home.
Kind of selling
the bread because I
had to do something
with it, because I
was making too
much of it to eat.
I had to give away.
And I was selling it
at my friend's shop
in the mission, Gravel & Gold.
And someone came in
there and saw the bread
and tried it, and liked it,
and saw my blog and said hey,
we want to write an
article about you,
and I was like--
(WHISPERING) you
want to write an
article about me?
My bread?
OK, let's do it.
And so they wrote an
article, and all of sudden I
got a bunch of
emails from people
I didn't know saying hey,
we read about your bread.
We want some.
And I was like, OK.
Wasn't really ready for
that, but Kathy actually
helped me set up-- what was it.
A Google forum?
Yeah, so we set
up a Google forum
so people could sign
up for the bread
and I got their
money through Paypal.
And then on Thanksgiving Day
I baked 60 loaves of bread
in my home oven.
There it is, right there.
And it's funny looking
at this picture now.
I'm like, that
bread totally sucks.
But I think at the time it
was the best I could do.
The type of things I do now
is, my previous job actually
was working at UC Berkeley
at the Lawrence Hall Science
on elementary and middle
school science curriculum.
And so I've got a love of
children and education,
and so we have
groups of children
come and visit us
every once in awhile.
And we take them
around the bakery
and show them our huge oven,
and then when you press a button
it shoots steam out the front.
It's very exciting.
But so I'm baking at home,
and I bake those 60 loaves
on Thanksgiving morning.
And it's very exciting
for me, and I say OK.
I'm going to go for it.
And I quit my job,
quit my day job.
And I'm thinking, I was
making a little bit of money
on bread, because I
was baking it at home.
I did have any employees,
I didn't have any expenses.
So if it costs you
a buck in flour,
and then you make it
into a loaf of bread,
make a few bucks right there.
It takes time, but
the moral of the story
is we're making it a
little bit of money,
but nowhere near enough
money to actually
live-- in San
Fransisco, especially.
And so, so I started
bartending at Amnesia.
And what I would
do there when-- I
didn't know that I
was going to do this,
but it's just turned out to
make sense-- is I'd bake bread
at home, or I'd
bake it, I also met
this is really great, generous
guy who owns a restaurant.
A few restaurants
in the East Bay.
And we're having a party
actually Friday night
at Penrose, any of you
are interested in coming
out and partying.
Charlie Hallowell,
and anyway, I'd
take the bread that I baked,
either at home or at Pizzaiolo
and bring it into the bar,
and hide it under the bar.
But I'd like, cut
up a few samples.
And so I'd be like, being a
bartender, and they'd come up
and they'd see the bread
they'd have a bite.
And they'd say, this is good.
Where is this?
Where is this from?
I know where you can get a
whole loaf of that stuff.
You got $5?
Then pretty soon, people
would come into the bar,
and I'd know as
soon they walked in.
Because they'd walk in
and they'd be like--
and they'd come up
and they be like--
is this where I
can get the bread?
Yeah, it is.
And I did that for
a little while,
but did that 'til April, 2011.
I wasn't cut out for
being a bartender.
Baking was more to
my liking and so
I said OK, I'm going
to stop the bartending,
and really go for it.
And I started baking full time.
So I was baking at
Mission Pie, which
is a pie bakery in The Mission.
I just walked in there
one day and asked them
if they'd let me
use their space,
rent space from them in
order to run my business.
And they were generous
enough to say yes.
And I was doing that,
and baking at Pizzaiolo.
So I was always baking
three days a week,
and I was doing it all
myself, and delivering it,
and I was probably making
around 250 loaves a week
or so that point.
This is me at Mission Pie.
Mission Pie was so influential,
because it allowed me
to-- you know, I
was baking at home,
and I was baking in this
wood fired oven at Pizzaoilo.
Neither of those ovens were
really meant for bread baking.
They weren't bread ovens.
The oven at Mission
Pie was a bread oven,
and it made a world
of difference.
You could press a button,
and then the chamber
will fill up with steam.
And steam is really helpful
for bread baking, which
you can do in your
home oven just as good
just with a baking
stone and a metal pot.
And the steam that's created
from the baking loaf of bread
is actually perfect for creating
steam saturated environment,
which will allow you to
get the most oven spring,
and get a nice crispy crust,
and really beautiful coloration.
So this is near Burning Man.
Just shooting a flame
thrower, pretty sweet.
That was one of the things
that was very appealing to me
about doing bread, and
turning it into my life,
was that I was able
to jump right into it
and immediately be my
own boss, because I
had my own ideas about how I
wanted to do the whole thing.
And the fact that I could
just start putting them
into practice right away
was really amazing to me.
And it definitely
was-- I don't think
I would have made it if
I got a job in a bakery,
or had to spend several
years in baking school.
Doing things like this was
really important to me,
apparently.
So this is the room that Jeremy
from Four Barrel brought me to.
And he said hey, I've
got an idea on the space.
I want to work on
something with you.
And he brings me here,
and I'm like, oh, OK.
Looks like we've got a lot of
work to do on this place, huh?
And we did, as I painfully
illustrated in the movie.
It took us about
a year and a half
from start to finish
to build out The Mill.
But it's done now.
These are just some trips from
my travels with my wife, Cathy.
This is Angkor Wat, and
doing some deep water soloing
in an island in Thailand,
jumping into a river in Lao.
That wasn't supposed
to be in there.
So I had that trip,
we had that trip
planned before I got
involved in The Mill,
building out The Mill.
And so we stuck to
it, but I came back
and we had a lot of work to do.
And I did as much
myself as I could.
This is me doing a little
grinding on the cart
that we used for coffee service
in The Mill for a little while
before the whole
space was built out.
Now the space is built out.
Top cellar is small.
Small, beautiful children.
No, what's really amazing
to me, one of the things
that's really
amazing is that we've
got a really solid customer
base of folks who come there
on a really regular basis.
So it really feels like we're
members of the community.
And that's really nourishing
to me, to lots of other people.
About three weeks
after we opened
we had to photograph
the cookbook,
which was not good timing.
But what can you do?
We'd already been pushing
it back for weeks and weeks,
so at that point, I
was hell bent on baking
every loaf of bread myself.
And so I was still doing that
at that point, which was silly.
A silly idea to think that I
could bake every loaf of bread
myself, but I didn't know
how to do anything else.
So I'd bake in the
morning, and then we'd
take off in the afternoon.
And we shot the whole thing
over the course of a week.
Erin Kunkel was
really, really fun
to work with, really talented.
So that was a terrible, terrible
thing that happened to me.
Two months after we opened
The Mill, I was on a bike ride
through Golden Gate Park.
And the fork on my bicycle
broke, and I fell on my face.
And it was very challenging,
but it was actually
a blessing in disguise.
Because I was
trying to do things
like bake every
single loaf of bread
myself, which is a
relic from the way
the business was
when it was just me.
But now it wasn't just me, it
was a whole team of people.
And a really talented team
of people that as soon
as I had to let go of the
business, it flourished.
And I didn't let go completely.
But I took 10 days
away from the bakery,
because I was like
in La La Land.
And I came back, and
everything was great.
And people were on
some level, they
were grateful that they
were able to take the reins
and run with them.
And it's still so amazing to me.
I'm filled with gratitude
when I go into that space
and see everybody working
so hard on this project.
It really fills me with love.
These are loafers, by the way.
And this is just a
pretty loaf of bread.
The bread is not
always, baking bread--
it depends what your
standards are, right?
What your end vision is
for whatever you're doing.
But we've got a very particular
thing that we're going for.
And it's very hard to get there.
There are many days
where the bread is still
wonderfully
delicious and pretty,
and I think 98% of people
don't care or notice
the difference from
one day to another.
But we obviously do, and
I'm almost never satisfied
with how the bread comes out.
And that's one of
the things that
keeps it really interesting,
is that it's very,
it's a finicky beast.
But this one came
out pretty good.
And we started doing pizza
on Monday nights at The Mill.
So every Monday night,
we do a different type
of vegetarian pizza, and it's
been really out of control.
So feel free to swing
through if you want.
There's a whole chapter
in the book on pizza.
So without further
ado, I think we
should start talking about
the book a little bit.
Or I'll talk a little
bit about this, toast.
So I don't know if any of you
were privy to the whole toast
thing that happened.
But we got a lot of flack
for our toast and ruining San
Francisco.
I'm glad that that's blown over.
We make toast at The Mill,
we think it tastes good.
Come try it if you like, but
don't if you don't want to.
And this is The Mill.
So it's up on Divisidero St,
between Fulton and Grove.
I'm there most the time,
come say hey if you want.
So the book "Josey Baker Bread"
is a beginner's bread baking
cookbook, and the
first two chapters
are a series of
recipes that are meant
to be followed sequentially.
So you start at the beginning.
You do recipe one,
two, three, four,
and each one builds on
the previous recipe.
And so the reason I did that
was because I was hearing from,
and I had the same
experience myself,
but hearing from lots
of people that they're
overwhelmed when you open
up a bread baking cookbook.
You're overwhelmed at
the idea of baking bread.
It's this mystical thing,
involves yeast-- terrifying.
But what I tried to do is
start at the beginning,
and only give you the
information that you really
need.
Not get all crazy about
temperature, and time,
and you need to shape
the loaf this way.
And there's a bulk
ferment, and then a proof.
But you can retard the
proof, and all these things
that when you're first
starting out it's like-- whoa.
I just want to make bread here.
And so that's
where we start out,
with a really, really basic loaf
with just bread flour, water,
salt, yeast.
You don't even need it at all.
And it's really flexible.
You could leave the dough in
your fridge for like a week,
or less than a week,
as long as you want.
And then you shape it into
a loaf and bake it up.
And then the next recipe
introduces a few other things.
We introduce whole wheat flour.
We introduce the idea of mixing
the dough in multiple stages,
and so on, and so forth.
And the second chapter
is all about sourdough.
I teach you how to make
your own sourdough culture.
And then the rest of the book
goes into all sorts of areas.
We've making bread
with different grains,
making pizza, pocket breads.
The last chapter is
sweets-- like cookies,
and fruit crumbles,
and cornbread,
cream scones, that
kind of stuff.
But it's been great, I've been
getting really good feedback.
So happy to answer any questions
anybody has about anything.
AUDIENCE: When I
bake bread at home
I feel like what's really
helpful to me is to be tasting
a bread and being really
picky about how will
the results are, and
really just doing
ridiculously picky about it.
How do you assess how
good your bread is?
How do you, like what are
things that you're looking for,
and stuff like that?
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah,
good question.
Yeah, I mean the
first thing obviously
that you can tell
is what it looks
like from the outside,
which can be very deceiving.
And that's a personal thing,
that's your own aesthetic,
and what you're going for.
But one thing that
we go for at The Mill
and that I suggest to
you go for in your home
is to go for a bold bake.
And so that means baking your
bread until the crust is really
the whole spectrum of
colors, but everywhere
from really dark
brown to really light.
And you get that spectrum
mostly in the ear
that's created from the
slash that you give it right
before the bread
goes in the oven.
But in order for your
bread to not be dried out
by baking it that
much, you need to have
kind of a lot of water
in your bread dough.
And so that helps the
interior of your bread
stay nice and moist while
the outside can get nice,
and flavorful, and crunchy.
So we've got the loaf,
so we go for a bold bake.
And what usually
comes along with that
is some crunch to your crust.
It's our preference.
We're talking about sourdough,
hearth loaves, specifically.
Then you cut into it, and I
like to have some irregularity
to the crumb, the crumb being
just the interior of the bread.
Crust and crumb, right?
Crumb is the inside, the
crust is the outside.
And that is where I can get
very particular about what
it looks like in there.
More than the pattern
of the bubbles inside,
I want the inside
to be supple, soft,
and to have the
appearance to have
a little bit of
glossiness, which
means that the starches
are fully gelatinized.
Gelated, I'm not sure
which is correct,
but just means that the
bread is fully baked.
Having a good amount of
oven spring on the bread,
and so that means that when
you put the loaf into the oven
it's going to undergo a period
of rapid expansion, which is it
mostly the gases that are
already in the bubbles
in there expanding.
And so that expansion
is called oven spring.
And so if when you slash your
loaf-- if you do it well,
if you've done
everything well, you'll
have a nice amount
of oven spring
which will lead to
something along these lines.
Which you see--
this was closed up
when we put it into the oven.
And I ran a razor like
that just along this part.
And so this was the cut I made,
lines up with here, and here.
And all of this is tearing.
The dough ripped itself apart
because it had so much vitality
in it.
So I like some of oven spring,
but it's a personal question.
Everybody can decide
for themselves.
AUDIENCE: So when you
started, you first baked
your first loaf of
bread, were you're
looking for a life change?
Like were you happy doing
what you were doing?
JOSEY BAKER: That's
a good question.
When I started my work at
the Lawrence Hall of Science,
that was my dream job.
And I totally loved it for
the first several years
that I was there.
And then I started to think
about doing something else,
and I didn't know what.
And actually, I was
really close to going back
to school for psychology.
I was going to apply to
CIS here in the city,
and I missed the deadline
for applications.
And when I realized it was
going to be a whole other year
before I could go,
I realized that that
wasn't the right
fit for me either.
And so I wanted to
do something else,
but I wasn't sure what
until I started baking.
And then it was really
not even like oh, this
can be my next job.
It was just oh man, I've got
to be doing this all the time,
and then figuring out how
to make it into a business
came after the fact.
It was sweet, I
lucked out I think.
AUDIENCE: So it seems
like bread has recently
gotten some fame about it.
Which is great, because
I love eating bread,
and I love making bread.
And it seems like every year
or so the New York Times
will run this big
article talking about--
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --Jim Lahey
and no knead bread,
or Chad Robertson from Tartine.
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This maybe
an unfair question,
but what do you think your
personal angle to bread is,
and how it differs from some
of the other bread celebrities?
JOSEY BAKER: No,
that's a cool question.
Yeah, I appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
He wears loafers.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
which is awesome.
Which I would do if it
didn't mean throwing away
three hours of work.
JOSEY BAKER: I
know what you mean.
Yeah, I'm just starting
to wonder that myself.
What is my angle in
this whole thing?
And in a way, I feel like
other people would actually
be better suited to
answer that than me,
because like I just said.
It really was not-- like
I didn't have any business
plan to the whole thing.
It was not a
calculated endeavor.
It was pretty improvisational,
the whole thing.
But what I'm realizing, and
this is like what I just said,
is that other people-- what
I'm hearing from lots of people
tell me is that what they
value about my approach
to the whole thing is
that it's casual, and fun,
and that it takes the terror
out of bread baking, which
for whatever reason-- I
think bread baking has
a certain mystique
around it right now
which is funny,
because back in the day
it was something that
everybody did at home
and there was no was
no hullabaloo about it.
You just baked because
that's the way you got bread.
And so what I found through
the process of bread
baking as a hobby was
I found a lot of peace
in the act of making bread.
And then I find a lot of
joy in the connections
that breaking bread can
foster between people.
And so the more people that can
find those things through it,
I think the better.
Because it's really, to me
it's a pretty magical thing
to engage in.
So maybe something
along those lines?
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Great
to have you back.
JOSEY BAKER: Thanks, man.
AUDIENCE: I was lucky enough
to be a proud and joyous eater
of the bicycle delivered
loaves that were here.
JOSEY BAKER: I remember you.
AUDIENCE: You buy many of
them, and then actually
give them to friends and so
forth who just enjoyed so much.
So one of the things
that was evident then,
is still evident now is
your sort of passion.
And sort of the joy you
take in what you're doing.
But you also say like,
1 in 50 set of loaves.
Like OK, this is good bread.
Otherwise, nah.
And then you also just now
spoke to sort of the peace,
or perhaps even meditative
quality to the act itself.
And I'm sort of curious.
OK, so that's a really
interesting combination
of feelings about something.
Like if I succeeded 1 in 50
times, I might be saying, hey,
maybe I should be
doing something else.
Admittedly, your tastes are now
very particular because you're
an expert, but nonetheless.
So I'm curious if you
could sort of tease
that, sort of what brings you
to the immense amount of work
involved in what you've
accomplished so far.
I mean, that's very evident
in all aspects of it.
So I'm curious, like why
did despair not drag you
into the floor?
JOSEY BAKER: That's
a great question.
I'll blab a little bit.
You just keep me on track, OK?
I think these days
actually, one of the things,
I mean it's always it's always
interesting and challenging.
And now, making
one loaf of bread
when you're first
starting out is
new, and different, and
interesting, and challenging.
And after you do
that for a while,
it starts to become
easier, right?
That gets complicated when you
start making 2, 4, 300 a day.
And so it's still
really challenging.
Like every day I have at the
bakery I'm like, holy crap.
This is hard.
This is hard to make
this much, and to have
everything go really well.
And then when the bread comes
out, the moment of truth.
You see how good a job you did.
And it is really
hard for the bread
to live up to this
idea I have of it.
And every once in
awhile, it does it.
And that is like
this carrot that
keeps dangling in front
of me, and keeps me--
the fact that it's elusive is
very intriguing, and seductive.
But that's my experience of it.
Now, our customers
experience of it
is that basically the
bread's the same every day.
And that's awesome.
The fact that we have people
coming back and buying
the bread regularly is
extremely flattering,
and I'm really grateful
that I can play that role.
But so it's through
two different lenses
that I have those experiences.
I have the really critical
side from my maker perspective,
and then I have the
really satisfied part,
which is from my relationship
with my customers.
So both of those things
mean I keep going.
AUDIENCE: So at
some point you went
from being some guy who
followed some recipes
and was making some decent
bread that you kind of liked,
and you kind of liked
doing it, to a point where
you know sort of what the 100
variables that you can alter
to affect the taste,
and the texture,
and the size, and the color,
and all that of your bread.
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm really interested
in how you got there.
JOSEY BAKER: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: How is it that you
made that transition from sort
of somebody who just
follows recipes to a baker--
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --right, who
really kind of knows
what you're doing?
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
Well, I still don't
know what I'm doing.
But no, I mean it is,
it's a process, right?
So there wasn't any one moment
where like it all clicked
or anything.
It's still clicking,
like every time
I'm in the bakery I'm
learning something new.
And being able to
more delicately pull
on all those strings as I
understand what exactly they're
connected to.
But one thing that I did
really early on-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: You may be
about to say this,
but I was going to ask if
there was a point at which you
started doing things like
experimenting-- saying OK,
let's on purpose, do
things in different ways
and see what it's like.
Knowing that probably n minus
1 of them will be really bad,
but you'll discover which is
the one that's really good.
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
I started doing that
pretty early on.
Yeah, and I was very, I
was meticulous about it.
And that is in part
just my disposition,
but also because
I would had just
been working in science
education for the last five
years.
And so I knew that that was the
way I was going to get answers
to my questions, and I had
really specific questions.
And so I think also having
the experience of not getting
it all laid out for
me by going to school
or working under someone
else, that kind of had
to be my approach
from the beginning.
I was doing the
investigation here,
and I was getting to decide
what the questions were.
So I went about it in a
pretty scientific way,
and having my buddy just
scribble out some instructions.
And then, really quickly
noticing that everybody
has a different way
of doing it, right?
And obviously there's
many different ways
to make a great loaf of bread.
Like there's many different ways
to do most things, and so, OK.
Well why does this method work?
And this method works, and
they're so totally different.
And so I had a lot
of energy that I
was ready to pour into
something, and bread became it.
And by making it my job very
quickly, all of sudden I
was baking all the time.
I mean, I was baking a lot
because I was interested in it.
But then I started selling
it, and then people
started asking me for it.
And so then I was just
really, that really
accelerated everything.
And it was always a really
rich learning experience,
because there wasn't
anybody saying, hey,
you need to make sure
that water is 75 degrees.
Well, why?
Well what happens if
I make it 80 degrees?
And by the way, I
didn't even measure
the temperature of the water.
Which any of you have
baked any bread before,
you know that the
temperature of the water
will really affect how
quickly your bread ferments.
The temperature of your dough.
Basically a warmer
dough ferments
quicker than a cooler dough.
Simple rule of thumb.
But I didn't even
take the temperature
of the water for the first
like, six or eight months
that I baked at Mission Pie.
And it was fine.
So if you're nervous about
taking the temperature,
just don't do it.
Does that kind of answer-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm kind of
curious about just like,
you mentioned the
community aspect.
And I think we're
super fortunate to live
in San Fransisco
where we have access
to wonderful talents like you.
JOSEY BAKER: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Just as
far as continuing
this, where you have
a community of people
who have amazing talents
when it comes to food.
Is there something that
you're a part of outside
of, now that you've
got this establishment,
your huge business.
You're growing, like
are there other things?
Like do you see sort of
a connection or a larger
community that's
becoming bigger hear
in San Fransisco than other
cities where we can support?
I mean I've love
seeing this, and I
love seeing it happen here
in San Fransisco rather
than other cities.
I'm just curious of
whether or not there's--
JOSEY BAKER: Meaning like
a formal organization?
Or just--
AUDIENCE: Like a collective of
artisanal baker's and others.
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah,
that's a great question.
I think, I'm not a member
of any formal organization
that's catered
specifically to that.
What I find--
AUDIENCE: Part of
the reason why I
ask is because it's
fascinating as you look
at how you established yourself.
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I'm sure it
was very scary at times
and challenging.
And so who did you turn to?
JOSEY BAKER: Gotcha.
AUDIENCE: There's people
who in similar ways
just establishing
themselves, and how do you
guys support each other?
JOSEY BAKER: So
one of the things
that was so helpful to me
from the very beginning
was that I was able to,
again, I would never
use this term in the moment, but
I was able to find mentors who
were people who were already
working in the industry who had
answers all these
questions I had.
And there are
certain organizations
that have that type
of framework set up,
like La Cocina in the Mission.
But without that guidance,
I would've been really lost.
And I think I was bold
enough or stupid enough
to just really
talk to anybody who
would talk about it with me.
And every once in a while
you can find someone
who you resonate with,
and who you can actually
have a relationship with like
Charlie Hallowell, and Jody
and Jeremy from Four Barrel,
and the owners of Mission Pie,
and Dave Miller out in Chico.
Like all those people
were so helpful in helping
me figure out what
my value system was,
and how to navigate
that whole thing.
So I don't have a great
answer though for you
as far as what, maybe someone
in the room knows about some--
AUDIENCE: Maybe you
should start one.
JOSEY BAKER: Maybe
I should start one.
AUDIENCE: I think you
have a great story,
so I'd just like,
spread the word.
JOSEY BAKER: I appreciate that.
It's one of the things
that I've been chewing on.
I'm trying right now to
not start any new projects,
but something along those lines
is something I've considered,
so thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I live near The Mill
in Western Edition.
And I every time I walk by
it's just so busy, so crowded.
Do you have any plans
of other locations?
Or when you look to the
future what do you see,
or what are your plans?
JOSEY BAKER: I don't want
to open another location
any time soon, mostly because
it was so much work to get it up
and running.
And now it's up
and running, and I
want to be in that for a while.
And if I was to
start something else,
I would just be in the
process of building again.
So no, I think what
we're going to focus on
for a while at least is
exploring different breads,
exploring work with
different grains,
building relationships
with California farmers.
That stuff is really, those are
the goals of building The Mill.
And now that we have it, we can
get to work on those things.
Is the idea of
opening a restaurant
where we serve toast and
coffee in the morning,
and pizza, beer at night,
is that exciting to me?
Hell yeah.
Will I maybe do
that at some point?
Very possibly, but not yet.
I'm going to start
work on another book
though which is going to be a
journey to my favorite bakers
around the country,
and exploring
the role of the
village baker today.
And translating their recipes
into recipes for the home cook.
It's just an excuse
to get to go hang out
with my favorite bakers.
AUDIENCE: So you described a
really interesting and somewhat
unique and idiosyncratic
path to how you got here.
I'm wondering how that affects
the way that you teach,
and mentor, and relate to the
people who work for you, right?
Because they're coming
into this thing which
now is kind of
established, but you
came into it sort
of from scratch
and having to learn
it all yourself.
So I'm wondering if that
affects the way that you
interact with them, and
teach, and mentor them.
JOSEY BAKER: Yeah.
We've had a growing team
of folks at the bakery.
Now we're up to 10 people,
and that's a great size.
And I can have a direct
relationship with everybody
that works for me.
And for now, that's what I want.
I don't-- I actively am not
looking to have the team grow
at all.
But I like that because of
that direct relationship
I get to have with everybody
who works for me, what I wanted
to build at The Mill was
really like a tight knit
little family.
A crew of people.
And to a large
extent we've done it.
We all spend a lot of
our free time together.
We like it and
respect each other
as coworkers and as people.
But it's interesting, because
I haven't hired anybody
as a baker who didn't
have any experience.
A few of the folks
had more experience
working in bakeries than I did.
Which wasn't too hard
because I didn't have much,
but we've had people join
the team who really didn't
have much experience in baking.
But they were really,
really interested,
and they were really
dedicated to it.
And they didn't already have
all of these ideas about how
we were going to
go about things.
Right?
And so we're able to start
and build from the ground up,
and sometimes
that's a lot easier
than having to unlearn
things that you've learned
from however long
you've been doing it
the way you've been doing it.
I, as much as possible,
try to remain really open
with all of my employees.
And I always say, I
say the best idea wins.
Which means if it's somebody's
first day and they come in,
and they don't know the way
we're used to doing things
and they ask a question or
they suggest doing something
radically different, if
you keep your mind open,
they might have a
brilliant solution
to a problem you didn't
even know you had.
And so sometimes that
happens, and sometimes it's
a stupid idea.
But you've got to keep
your eyes open to it.
Thank you so much for coming,
I really appreciate it.